ça ne s'est pas très bien passé partout
hier au parc des buttes chaumont à paris
des centaines de personnes se sont
regroupées autour d'une enceinte et ont
vite transformer le parc en discothèque
alors ça fait énormément parler dites
moi ce que vous en pensez c'est parti
regarder
[Musique]
battus
[Applaudissements]
alors j'aime bien dire est ce que vous
comprenez ça est ce que vous comprenez
que les jeunes puissent craquer ou pas
de ligne que là ça va trop loin j'ai
bien non et en plus très franchement
c'est de la provocation et je ne crois
pas du tout à l'improvisation
les buttes chaumont s'est répété pour
être fait si beau qu'il le savait sont
venus là c'est une façon je trouve de
faire un doigt d'honneur à toute la
france je n'aime pas ça du tout
heureusement qu'il est con on voit que
là c'est une question de génération à
part delphine delphine c'est un petit
peu biaisé puisque dell streak 7 une
question de génération va autour de la
table a été très choqués on va devoir
donner la parole aux plus anciens
nicolas g isabelle delphine nicolas non
mais on nous prend pour des dindons à
nous montrer les images vont nous prend
pour des c aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il ya
pile je suis une personne en réanimation
parle du variant indien qui est en train
d'en reparler dans un instant on aura
justement il se qualifie c'est ce que
vous trouvez ça c'est dur pour la
jeunesse je le comprends mais enfin
est-ce qu'on peut tolérer ce genre de
rassemblements non moi je pense à leurs
voisins je pense à leurs familles je
pense à leurs grands parents
je pense à tous les gens qui sont autour
d'eux ça leur ait conneries guillaume
c'est marrant parce qu'on parle de fêtes
clandestines mais en fait elle n'est pas
du tout la chine c'est à la vue de tous
ils sont filmés ça les dérange pas donc
on voit qu'il ya un vrai une vraie
sensation de ras-le-bol chez plein de
jeunes moi je les comprends tout à fait
faut savoir que ces jeunes là y'en a qui
ont pas fait la fête depuis un an qui
n'ont pas eu d'interaction sociale
depuis un an donc c'est tout à fait
normal qu'ils se réunissent est qui et
qui profitent un peu
bernard n'ont d'abord c'était un tout
petit anniversaire ils étaient à peine
une vingtaine d'accords que comme disons
mis au départ mais quand ils ont mis la
saône à tout le monde c'est ramener tout
le monde à rappliquer ah ouais ouais
ouais donc voilà bon maintenant
évidemment que tout le monde en a
ras-le-bol on peut comprendre les jeunes
évidemment évidemment c'est triste il
faut pas le faire il faut encore
supporter quelques mois mais on peut les
comprendre il faisait tellement beau
c'était tellement grave mais faut pas le
faire le film mais moi la première j'ai
envie de refaire la fête on a une
discussion fait la fête vous mais bien
sûr c'est vrai que j'ai une discothèque
axonais j'aimerais mais rien que par
rapport à toutes ces discothèques là par
rapport au milieu hospitalier faut être
solidaire ccco c'est nul c'est de passer
et faire la fête
bernard disait que c'était
c'était pour l'occasion d'un
anniversaire et d'ailleurs c'était le
mien c'est pour ça que ça marche bien
et c'est son anniversaire ce soir c'est
notre chauffeur de salle il est auto
data très bien est restée coite très
bonnes interventions stratégiques
n'était plus drôle que tout le monde a
dit notamment
simon
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis désolé alors pour le court
monfils aussi arriver même faire la fête
mais on se retrouve à benchikha
déconfiture mais pardonnez moi oui les
jeunes sont malheureux mais ils sont pas
plus malheureux que les agriculteurs que
les restaurateurs que tous les magasins
fermés donc moi j'aime pas le clivage
honnêtement et dans peu de temps ils
pourront sortir ça sert à quoi de tout
risquer de maintenant qu'on est à qu'à
une encablure de la science à une
encablure bas bien entendu que moi je
suis pas pour ce que je vois mais je
peux comprendre c'est sûr qu'on peut
tous les comprendre je pense autour de
cette table a presque ce qui m'embête de
voir sur ces vidéos c'est que là ils
sont vraiment collé pourquoi vous coller
autant vous avez un grand parc
éloignez vous un peu enfin je veux dire
la la c'est abusé ce qu'on voit là mais
par contre oui je les comprends eric et
on vous aussi vous avez une petite
soirée à six ou sept dans 1,6 dans un
appartement de croix ce week-end
notamment que c'était votre anniversaire
j'ai vu ça sur les réseaux sociaux
on a tous fait un test antigénique ah
ouais d'accord voilà négatif et bien
faites un test la semaine prochaine
également
ats savoir si vous avez toujours du
boulot les jeunes en permanence que
malgré tout il n'y a jamais eu de ce
sport en extérieur
il ya plein de virologues qui disent que
bon il ya eu la reille vous savez à noël
y avait une règle avec plein de jeunes
deuil national kloster 3 dehors
globalement quand même ça se passe
beaucoup mieux changer la vie d'ailleurs
là-dessus géraldine active et red bull
ont gêné la craque complètement je sais
mère jerry castaldi temps mais c'est
vrai que c'est condamnable mais
franchement ça fait un an plus d'un an
qui sont ils sont cloîtrés les noms
peuvent plus moi je me bats avec mes
enfants tous les week-ends pour aller
une sortie pour les un dîner il faut dix
ans vous voyez pas quand ils sortent le
plus triste est que son ca presque mieux
qu'ils fassent ça dehors c'est bien fait
pour pendant l'hiver qui ont été
organisées avec dada 20 à 30 à 40 ans
soignant alors regardez choqué ça quand
tu bosses pas de choquer 40 points ça
représente un petit peu le
le ratio ici un lèche iric